North Korea says it now has a missile
that can strike anywhere in the US
including Washington DC Kim Jong Un's
regime successfully launched its third
intercontinental ballistic missile
yesterday northeast of Pyongyang the
missile stayed in the air for 53 minutes
and traveled about 600 miles before
landing in the Sea of Japan North Korean
state media released a statement
overnight saying we have finally
realized the great historic cause of
completing the state nuclear force it
also said they hope to defend North
Korea quote from the US imperialists
nuclear blackmail policy and nuclear
threat Ben Tracy is in Tokyo with more
on the newest launch Ben good morning
good morning so North Korea had gone 75
days without launching a missile and
some thought that might be a sign that
sanctions were working or that Kim
jong-eun was ready for diplomacy but it
turns out they were working on a new
kind of ICBM one with much greater range
North Korean state TV triumphantly
announced the launch of its new missile
the ha song 15 and showed kim jeong-hoon
signing the launch order the missile
appears to be a more advanced version of
the ha song 14 which North Korea twice
tested in July during Wednesday's launch
the new missile was purposefully lofted
high into space and reached a maximum
altitude of nearly 2800 miles analysts
say that fired on a standard trajectory
the missile could travel approximately
80 100 miles far enough to hit anywhere
in the United States it went higher
frankly than any previous shot they've
taken it's a research and development
effort on their part continue building
ballistic missiles that could threaten
everywhere in the world six minutes
after North Korea's test
South Korea fired three missiles off its
east coast a reminder that it could
attack the North's launch sites if
needed it is a situation that we will
handle president Trump labelled Kim
jong-un's regime a state sponsor of
terror
despite its claims of a usable weapon
it's still not known if the North's new
missile could support an actual nuclear
warhead and survive re-entry into the
Earth's atmosphere but analysts say the
regime keeps making progress I think
they have a absolute terror of a US
attack and so I think that they feel
like they have to accelerate their
testing as fast as possible so that they
have a weapon system that they feel will
deter us North Korea has now launched at
least 20 missiles this year this last
one they launched in the middle of the
night and with a mobile launch pad
making it much harder to detect Nora
alright Ben Tracy in Tokyo thank you